me now is award-winning independent
journalist glenn greenwald
glenn it's great to see you tonight i
don't i don't know what's more
insulting about nira tandon's
confirmation trouble that it's
being blamed on her tweets or her sexism
yeah or her racism it's just the
standard democratic playbook
you know i think it's really important
to note laura that long before she was
nominated
the people who had the most contempt for
near tanden were actually people on the
left particularly supporters of bernie
sanders
because nira tandon comes from the
hillary clinton wing she's basically a
hillary apparatchik that's where she got
her start
and that's where she for years had her
loyalty and so
when bernie sanders went in 2016 and
then again in 2020 it wasn't just mean
tweets
she was constantly accusing sanders
and his entire movement of being racist
of being misogynist
of being kremlin agents i don't know how
many times she has called me
an agent of moscow it's not mean tweet
she's just a vicious defamer she goes
around slandering everybody the way
other people change their socks
and she's not so much a leftist as she
is a corporatist she spent the last
several years
raising money from silicon valley from
wall street
from the united arab emirates one of the
most repressive regimes on the planet
for her think tank and then censoring
her employees who wrote against them
she's really like the worst embodiment
of washington
sleaze which is why she's earned so much
enemy on the left and the right
yeah i think that's an excellent point
and it's better framed frankly that way
that she
vacuumed up a lot of cash at the center
for american progress from
big corporate entities those same
entities whose
whose top board members and
and senior officers in turn gave tons of
money to biden
so in a way this is kind of a payoff all
the way around is it not glenn
yeah absolutely you know i think it's
interesting to note that the chairman of
the
budget committee that has to approve her
is is senator sanders who she spent the
last five or six years
viciously slandering and he hasn't said
yet how he's going to vote
precisely because his main concern is
exactly that i have friends who work for
that think tank who were supposedly
independent writers at the blog that
they once controlled
and if they would go to write about any
of these corporate donors
she would censor them all the time they
prepared this huge report
about the new york police department
under michael bloomberg
and when the report was prepared the
entire chapter on the nypd was removed
by nera
after bloomberg donated more than a
million and a half dollars
to the center for america she's just
corrupt on top of all of her
other terrible attributes why would you
want somebody in government
running the budget who is beholden to
the wealthiest most powerful corporatist
interest obviously that's who she's
going to serve
and glenn something else that we've
talked about before with you
involves what's happening in washington
dc right now
tonight which is razor wire
hundreds thousands of u.s national guard
troops
huge ominous looking fencing
and no sense at all that this is going
to be removed
as far as i can tell ever
and the cost of it is probably going to
be about a billion dollars
by the fall and what are we protecting
the capital from exactly what they can't
answer that question
going back to the issue we talked about
before
yeah i mean that's why it's so important
to them to insist that what happened at
the capitol on january 6
as lamentable as it was was not merely a
riot but an insurrection or even a coup
even though nothing is where is that
insurrection insurrections don't happen
for three hours and then disappear
they said there were going to be violent
protests all over the country on
inauguration day a total of nine people
showed
up at all 50 state capitals they want to
inflate these threats because the
democrats are in control of the
government
and if you can militarize washington
infiltrate
groups eavesdrop on people the way the
fbi was doing on that day including
members of congress
that gives you a great power but you
have to keep the population in fear
which is why they're inflating that
threat and so intent on doing so
yeah and and glenn honestly if someone
who lives in south america
it looks like you're in a a corrupt
regime that is that is where the
government is afraid of what's what the
people are going to do
like because the government's not
serving the people that's what it looks
like it i've
since i since i was i think in el
salvador in the 80s
i have not seen or maybe in soviet
russia i've not seen anything like this
that i that i'm seeing right now in dc
it's disgraceful
and they're threatening to have a wider
net of surveillance
without any clear indication as to why
they want to surveil more more people
they won't cite any evidence
they say oh we have to go behind closed
doors that's what they said yesterday
you know i think it's ultimately really
a way of simultaneously
raising fear levels because when you put
people in a state of fear they acquiesce
to authoritarian power
but also it's a signal it's trying to
make people
feel threatened by them saying you
better not challenge us in any way we
are essentially militarized we've armed
and militarized
all of washington that's called the
people's house you're supposed to be
able to come and go
outside of the capitol and the fact that
there was a riot on one day
does not justify having the military
take the nation's capital
and essentially turn it into as you say
what looks like the green zone in
baghdad at the height of the
iraq war but that is a really good way
to keep the population fearful
of these threats but also fearful of the
government which is a very poor state of
affairs
and and over at msnbc um they're they're
not so much concerned about
that increase in domestic spying but
that
it's just pointed in the right direction
watch
the argument we keep hearing is well we
don't have domestic terror laws in place
in the u.s if we did would that not
excessively harm peaceful protesters
that want racial justice
right stephanie because comparing what
happened on january 6 to what happened
last summer is completely conflating the
issue
what happened last summer is mostly
peaceful protesters who were
attacked by police officers glenn
look the the point is more surveillance
of americans who are not committing
crimes is what everyone's worried about
and it's patriot act on steroids
whatever we want to call
this they're poised to do it
yeah i mean it became a consensus among
i think most americans but for a long
time obviously on the left and
in liberalism that there was an
overreaction to 9 11 9
and i agree there was an overreaction
but 911 involved two huge jets being
flown into
downtown skyscrapers and the pentagon
thousands of people killed at once and
even there that was an overreaction
this was this was a riot in which none
of the protesters themselves killed
anybody they themselves were killed we
don't know how brian cycling died
but that's what they're trying to do
they want to use the power of the
federal government
against their political adversaries use
the power of the fbi
the nsa the cia surveillance detention
and to do that they have to keep fear
levels high and to convince americans
this isn't just a different political
faction this is domestic terrorists
these are white nationalists
and therefore you need to give us
emergency powers against your fellow
citizens
uh and if citizens are adding each other
out neighbor against neighbor family
member against family member
and all with the help of big tech as
you've written about
so persuasively glenn great to see you
tonight thank you so much